hey this is Sarah with redstone our
Sarang calm and today I want to talk to
you about the different IV gauges you'll
be encountering in the hospital setting
as a nurse right here I have the
different type of IV gauges that you'll
normally see as a nurse there is the 22
which is the blue one the 20 gauge which
is the pink one and the 18 gauge which
is the green one as a nurse you will be
using these so much that you will
memorize these different colors but when
you first start out you'll be a little
confused and typically there's a little
rhyme you can memorize or you can think
of your own thing how you can memorize
it is this run with blue 22 Green is 18
and then pink is in the middle also you
may see a yellow color which is a
pediatric needle sometimes as a nurse we
like to use that on patients who have
limited IV IV access or have very small
veins and we just need to give an IV
drug or you can see a gray which is the
16 gauge and that's typically used in
surgery or in the ICU and it's a very
large can um so you see those those are
what those are but typically you're
going to be using these colors so what
is the difference exactly they look the
same from here but there is a little bit
of a difference I'm going to show you
right here we have the smallest and the
largest in this group and you well you
can tell by when I slide these off the
needles this is the cannula because when
you inject that it'll slide off just
like that and use this little wing area
to help you do that and see whenever I
slide the 22 offs pay attention that
cannula and the 18 gage pay attention
canula see how this is a lot thicker
than this 22 this allows you the 18
because it's larger to give blood your
red blood cells won't break up allows
drugs to be pushed fast
bolus 'as you can do a lot of things
with this they the 22 gauge it's good
for if you're having an out patient come
in for testing or you just need to get
some drugs or just saline or anything
like that so before you ever start an IV
on a patient you always need to ask
yourself what type of IV size will my
patient need patients hate to be stuck
with IVs it's the number one thing they
do not like so always make sure that you
pick the right correct gauge for your
patient so they won't have to be stuck
multiple times because there's never
like you start a 2200 patient and CT
calls and says that the doctor ordered a
CT P protocol and they need an 18-gauge
and then you have to go in and tell the
patient you have to poke them again they
will not like that so always evaluate
that so say that you have a patient that
came to you they've been admitted from
the doctor's office and they're coming
in with a GI bleed you should
automatically say that patients get an
18-gauge because most likely you're
going to have to transfuse blood and
check your Hospital protocol because
these 18 gages are sometimes really hard
to get into some patients because they
have very small veins some hospitals
allow you to use 20 gages to give blood
so it really depends on your Hospital
protocol so always check that so I'm
going to show you a little bit about
these IVs how they're set up and show
you what they do I'm going to use the 18
gauge right here you will see this
little button this is your safety what
you get your IV in the patient you're
you will hit this button and it will
retract the needle into this area right
here so let's pretend we're starting an
IV on a patient we do our prep we get it
we get them ready we find our vein and
we're ready to stick once you stick the
patient and you hit the vein in this
little chamber right here you will get a
flash of blood that will let you know
that you've hit the name after that I
always like to advance a little bit more
and just to get that needle really good
in that vein because sometimes you hit
it and you advance and it won't advance
at all and that's because generally
you're not in the vein all the way so
just insert a little bit more so once
you do that you will take your finger
and there's this little area right here
I'm able to guide it into the vein it
just literally slides in the vein and
after you get it slid in you will hit
your white button and it will Schrute
track the needle all the way in here
very very awesome design because this is
decreased needle sticks among nurses and
doctors because we're starting IVs on
patients who have diseases such as
hepatitis and HIV and one time I had a
professor who was teaching me how to
start IVs and she was sharing a story
with us about a friend who was a nurse
who worked in a gel setting and there
was a big fight in the gel and some
prisoners were hurt so she had received
a patient to her bay area that she had a
treat and she started an IV on him and
after she started the IV IVs a long time
ago they didn't have the safety so she
started the IV she said the IV beside of
her with a needle still engaged and he
had grabbed the IV and he had just
stabbed her several times all over her
body she didn't die from that but the
patient had HIV and hepatitis she did
contract HIV and she died I think three
or five years later and she had kids and
everything was
very very tragic story so always use
your safety and if you're ever in a
situation with the patient because we
take care of patients who do have
violent histories who are there from
jail settings always protect yourself
with that always use your safety so that
was a little bit about IV gauges if you
ever have any questions about IV gauges
or anything like that come to my website
register nurse orange comm there's a
forum there we connect with other nurses
and I'm going to be making a video on
how to start IV so please check that out
and if you like this video share it with
your friends and thank you so much for
watching